all right we're gonna start we're gonna
go very slow tonight because a lot of
new information Robert Muller his team
of partisan investigators they want to
face off with the President of the
United States but today president
Trump's attorneys flatly rejected
rightly so Muller's interview terms they
have countered with a proposal of their
own in a statement the attorney for
President Trump
former New York City Mayor Rudy Giuliani
wrote we are restating what we have been
saying for months it is time for the
office of the Special Counsel to
conclude its inquiry without further
delay now the former mayor is now
predicting that the investigation could
be over by the first he'll be right here
on this show with more details in just a
few moments without a doubt president
Trump should be aware now Muller his
merry band of anti-trump deep state
sycophants Hillary Clinton Obama
democratic donors what's happening here
we all pretty much agree on they are
laying a perjury trap for the President
of the United States Muller should not
get what he wants
the president his attorney should not
give in the president should not sit
down for an interview now tonight we
have yet another example of just how
corrupt and how flawed Muller's
witch-hunt really is according to a
shocking new report tonight from the
hills John Solomon Christopher Steele
remember him the former foreign spy
responsible for the Clinton bought and
paid for dossier oh we now know he was
also paid by your FBI your dollars under
Jim Comey while they were desperately
trying to influence the ongoing counsel
with the hunt into so-called Russian
collusion and it gets worse Bruce or the
fourth highest ranking member of the DOJ
was trying to help Christopher Steele do
it this is months after Steele was fired
for leaking got 11 payments from the FBI
on July 16 2016 before the election
Steele wrote to or quote I spoke to my
old colleagues last week they assured me
they would not stand in the way of our
re-engagement with the bureau or texted
back I will pass along to my colleagues
thanks and on November 18th after the
election Trump won now Muller's
witch-hunt by the way it was now
underway Steele writing quote I am
presuming you
nothing back from your special counsel
colleagues on the issues you kindly put
to them from me and then still goes on
to say to say this is disappointing
would be an understatement certain
people have been willing to risk
everything to engage with them in an
effort to help them reach the truth now
yeah right just like there's truth in
that phony unverified uncorroborated
debunked dossier that the Clinton
campaign used to smear then candidate
Donald Trump the same Russian lies that
were used before the election as the
foundation for the Muller witch hunt and
the OP research used to mislead a FISA
Court on for not one but four separate
occasions for judges so the government
literally can spy on an opposition party
candidate and a trump campaign associate
and meanwhile according to a brand new
report report from our own Sarah Carter
a post election 2016 handwritten
document from Bruce or listing the names
of struck and Paige and others in the
FBI is also raising questions tonight
about the extent of wars communications
with the bureau and according to some
other newly unearthed texts tonight
we're also learning that Steele was
concerned about the US Senate's inquiry
into the dirty dossier probably because
the contents were full of Russian lies
and outright propaganda and by the way
he even said so himself in an
interrogatory in England he said it's
raw intelligence I have no idea if this
is true maybe 50/50 really not only did
he peddle his Clinton an FBI bought and
paid for lies to you the American people
to sway an election the bulk of that
information that is false
Russian lies to get a FISA warrant as
top officials as I said four separate
times like two FISA Court judges to spy
on an opposition party candidate then he
turns around and tries to peddle his
lives through Bruce or remember his wife
Nelly
well she helped build the lies for
fusion GPS the dossier why did what did
they do with it they wanted to get it to
Muller post-election
to destroy
President Trump after the fact that they
lost they tried to influence the
election it didn't work then they tried
to destroy the president it is a
National disgusting despicable disgrace
the biggest abuse of power by the top
DOJ at FBI officials in this country by
the way not rank and file and according
to Sullivan's report we'll go back to
that these communications between Bruce
or and Christopher Steele they were
going on until late November 2017 well
it's more than a year after the FBI
supposedly officially caught off all
ties with Steele because he was leaking
and lying about potentially classified
information to the media again to peddle
his lies to influence the outcome of our
election now this all comes on the heels
of last night's shocking report that
showed that Christopher Steele was
working closely with Bruce or before and
after the 2016 election again to spread
the lies from Steele's dirty dossier he
had no faith in those lies throughout
the highest levels of what is supposed
to be our fair and unbiased justice
system equal justice under the law equal
applications of the law now at the time
or again the fourth highest ranking
member of Obama's Department of Justice
however he since been demoted because of
his unethical ties to steel infusion GPS
now Sarah Carter John Solomon they will
be joining us in a moment with more
details
these are shocking new developments it
is far worse than we ever thought but
first we are also currently tracking
another investigation into election
hacking now according to WikiLeaks the
Senate Intel committee has now requested
to interview WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange now senator burrs office has not
confirmed the request but if this true
it's about time after all remember
WikiLeaks they were the ones that
actually release those hacked emails and
unlike so many other so-called
journalists here in America we actually
took the time we went to England we sat
down and we interviewed Julian Assange
right here on the show and on my radio
show and he said to us then no
government actor was involved in the
hacking you might remember take a look
did Russia give you this information or
anyone
associated with Russia our source is not
a state party so the answer for our
interactions is no you did not get this
information about the DNC John Podesta
see males can you tell the American
people a thousand percent you did not
get it from Russia or everybody
associated with Russia we can say we
have said repeatedly over the last two
months that our source is not the
Russian government and it is not a state
party now I would assume he knows where
he got it and probably has the proof so
let's let this country see where
WikiLeaks got the information from we're
going to keep you posted when or if the
Senate Intel does in fact interview
Julian Assange and by the way the house
they need to do the same thing the
American people you deserve the truth
but tonight regardless so we think about
WikiLeaks it's irrelevant we know one
thing for certain President Trump in no
way colluded with Russia and instead the
president has been extremely tough on
Vladimir Putin's hostile regime and
today we have one more example tough new
US sanctions levied against Russia in
response to an assassination attempt of
a former British spy conducted with
chemical or biological weapons now these
new sanctions will be applied to all
Russian state-owned businesses and will
reportedly affect 70% of the Russian
economy gee I thought the president was
compromised by Putin that's what fake
news tell us tells us or NBC News is
suggesting he might actually be a
Russian agent President Trump now while
the president makes serious policy
decisions and as he's conducting
consequential peace through strength
diplomacy Oh many on the far left
they are obsessing over ice the US
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
Agency now as part of their grand plan
to get open borders many on the Left
want to band together and ban ice
altogether earlier this week we sent
Tommy Lehren to Portland Oregon to
interview some of these anti-ice
activists so small portion take a look I
don't know if you've seen the last
couple of weeks but your city has been
kind of home to some protein
seeing some controversy a lot of
surrounding your mayor and the occupy
ice movement right familiar with any of
that what do you think about it I think
that they should be able to protest I
don't know if they need to be abolished
I think we need to look seriously at the
policies that are being practiced at the
moment Fox News yeah you're there too
but I'm nice don't care you don't like
Fox News no because Fox News day is
nothing but a bunch of lies well she
found a fan stay tuned we're gonna have
Tommy's full coverage coming up you're
not gonna believe how out of touch with
reality some of these people really are
all right now let's return to the
horrific breaking story out of New
Mexico a father of a missing disabled
three year old son has been arrested at
a squalid camp that's linked to Islamic
extremists during his arrest eleven
children were found on this compound
where it is believed weapons training
was conducted
now with plans of course to use the
children in future school shootings the
individual arrested was the son of a
Brooklyn Imam who was named as an
unindicted co-conspirator in the 1993
World Trade Center attack now sadly the
remains of the young child were also
found on this compound a scary tragic
story will continue to follow and we
also have another topic to get to and it
comes to us right here in New York City
sorry I pay high taxes I'm stuck here
far-left mayor Conrad bill de blasio has
a new favorite villain you're looking at
it right now it's right during a recent
interview comrade de Blasio blamed Fox
News for dividing America he tells The
Guardian quote if you could remove News
Corp from the last 25 years of American
history we would be in an entirely
different place yeah that's true we'd
only have one opinion on the news from
the far left a universal opinion because
they're all a bunch of sheep a utopian
dream for comrade de Blasio and like a
true left-wing extremist well Conrad de
Blasio detests diversity of thought
that's not good imagine 30 years without
rush oh let's see 30 years without talk
radio 23 years without Fox News all
right finally tonight our last topic
covers
a seven of the trial of the century the
2005 tax and bank fraud charges against
Paul manna for remember no collusion has
nothing to do with Donald Trump nothing
to do with the campaign nothing to do
with Russia and while team Muller is
embarrassing themselves and their
attempt to put the screws on Manta for
it as judge Ellis said to get him sing
or to compose against President Trump so
they can impeach a prosecute him well
it's most prosecutors were actually
feeling the heat from the presiding
judge TSL us the third yesterday judge
Ellis paraded Muller's legal team and
even accused one prosecutor of being
such a tough guy he was tearing up a
little cry-baby
today judge Ellis reportedly urged the
prosecution to quote focus sharply speed
up the pace of the trial saying quote
judges should be patient they made a
mistake when they confirmed me and
meanwhile Manta Ford's attorneys once
again called out what is the
questionable character of the star
witness Ric gates pointing out that he
had up to four extramarital affairs on
top of oh let's see embezzlement lying
extortion and could have faced if he
didn't get the freak get out of jail
free card from Muller could have faced
290 years in jail Wow all for 290 years
in jail or say something about this guy
I think I'll take the jail I don't think
so now as always we'll continue to
update you in this trial conducted by
Muller's
team of witch hunters this has
absolutely zero to do with Russia
nothing to do with collusion nothing to
do with the campaign nothing to do with
Trump 2005 put the screws to him so he
sings or composes all right